[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa el espacio de
france 24 para revisar en profundidad
las historias de nuestro continente
otro golpe contra el legado del
expresidente mexicano enrique peña
nieto- su secretario de defensa salvador
cienfuegos fue detenido en eeuu y es
señalado de narcotráfico por la misma
corte que condenó a joaquín el chapo
guzmán caravana indígena para exigir
seguridad al gobierno cerca de 500
vehículos partieron desde el suroeste de
colombia hacia la capital luego de que
el presidente e iván duque se negara a
reunirse con ellos y enviará en su lugar
a una delegación estamos en la recta
final de las elecciones presidenciales
en eeuu y en nuestro segmento especial
camino a la casablanca revisamos la
importancia del voto latino en florida
y vamos de inmediato con nuestra
historia principal
eeuu acudió a mexico con la detención de
quien era el comandante del ejército
durante el gobierno de enrique peña
nieto- salvador cienfuegos fue arrestado
en los ángeles a petición de la dea le
imputan tres cargos relacionados con
narcotráfico y lavado de dinero los
señalan de haber utilizado su poder para
proteger a los cárteles y ayudarlos a
encontrar embarcaciones para traficar
drogas entre otros delitos
es la primera vez en la historia en
méxico que un secretario de defensa es
detenido y el general salvador
cienfuegos quien ocupó el cargo desde
2012 hasta 2018 durante el sexenio de
enrique peña nieto- fue arrestado en los
ángeles a petición de la dea es acusado
de narcotráfico el mandatario andrés
manuel lópez obrador aseguró que se
trata de una muestra de la
descomposición que reinaba antes de la
llegada a la presidencia esto
es una
muestra inequívoca
la descomposición
de regir
d
cómo
sí
fue
degradando
función pública
la función gubernamental en el país en
efecto se trata de un nuevo golpe al
gobierno de peña nieto tras la
extradición desde españa del ex director
de la petrolera estatal pemex emilio
lozoya acusado de recibir sobornos de
odebrecht no existe ninguna
investigación en mexico que vincula el
general cienfuegos con el narcotráfico
pero la pesquisa existente en nuevayork
es la que se adelanta como parte del
juicio contra genaro garcía luna el
secretario de seguridad del ex
presidente felipe calderón es la misma
corte que condenó a cadena perpetua a
joaquín el chapo guzmán
y una caravana indígena partido de la
ciudad colombiana de cali hacia bogotá
para pedirle al gobierno de iván duque
acciones frente a la ola de masacres el
presidente colombiano no atendió el
primer llamado de la minga por lo que
los indígenas emprendieron su marcha
hacia la capital para exigirle
respuestas a sus demandas
cansados de la violencia en sus
territorios al menos cinco mil indígenas
emprendieron su marcha hacia bogotá
vienen desde el cauca en el suroeste de
colombia
el departamento que alberga la mayor
población indígena del país según el
censo de 2018 en cauca hay más de 308
mil indígenas y es el segundo
departamento con mayor población
originaria del país de acuerdo con el
consejo regional indígena del cauca
estos indígenas pertenecen a 8 grupos
étnicos y viven en 26 de sus 39
municipios estos grupos originarios
arriesgan su vida por defender sus
tierras en la región azotada por grupos
criminales y el narcotráfico que se
disputa al control de los territorios
abandonados por la ex guerrilla de las
farc según la asociación de cabildos
indígenas del norte del cauca en 2020
fueron asesinados 76 de sus líderes
porque nos están matando están matando a
los líderes con mucho más fuerza que
antes donde se incrementaron también las
masacres y las formas de violencia en
nuestros territorios el ministerio del
interior recordó que el gobierno le ha
cumplido a la minga con inversiones que
superan unos 89 millones de dólares
entre 2019 y 2020 pero los
se insiste en que más allá del dinero es
su indefensión ante estos grupos la que
ponen en riesgo su vida
empezamos nuestro segmento especial
camino a la casa blanca a dos semanas
para las elecciones esto es lo que usted
necesita saber el presidente de donald
trump y el candidato demócrata joe biden
se enfocaron en florida esta semana un
estado clave que otorga a 29 delegados
al colegio electoral el organismo que
elige al presidente de eeuu y donde se
requieren 270 para ganar se trata de un
swing states es decir pendular o bisagra
quien no tiene una tradición clara
demócrata o republicano
los latinos allí representan el 26 por
ciento de la población pero su voto no
es homogéneo si bien históricamente los
hispanos se han identificado con los
demócratas debido a su origen la
diáspora cubana venezolana y colombiana
tiende a ser más conservadora ya que en
el caso de venezuela y cuba vieron como
los gobiernos de izquierdas llevaron a
sus países a las crisis mientras que en
colombia se asocia con la extinta
guerrilla de las farc en un mitin en
sanford son pablo de los dos vecinos
suramericanos crítico del acuerdo de paz
del gobierno de juan manuel santos con
la ex guerrilla de las farc y celebró la
puesta en libertad del ex presidente
colombiano álvaro uribe vélez además
vinculó a joe biden con el llamado
castrochavismo el neologismo para
referirse a las políticas de los
fallecidos fidel castro y hugo chávez
por su parte bardem y intentó alejarse
de los señalamientos diciendo que
precisamente le ganó al representante
del ala más izquierdista de su partido
[Música]
vamos a miami para hablar con nuestro
corresponsal anthony welsch anthony te
pregunto en cifras qué porcentaje de
votos representan los venezolanos y los
colombianos en miami
pues si natalia primer todo para
entender cómo se distribuye ese mapa
electoral aquí en florida hay que
entender que es 26 4% de los hispanos
que van a votar o que son elegibles para
votar representan el 1 millón poco más
de un millón y medio de personas en este
estado la mayor parte del pastel se la
llevan los cubanos con unos 650 mil
personas y luego estarían los
colombianos unas 190.000 y ya por último
los la nueva tanda de de exilio
venezolano que ha llegado a florida
completamente al sur que representarían
unos 50 mil por eso la campaña de joe
biden y también la detona al tram
especialmente se está fijando en esos
votos porque básicamente porque si nos
remontamos hace cuatro años
hillary clinton perdió en este estado
por tan sólo 130 mil votos
y por qué no hacen mella entre los
hispanos en florida de las palabras de
trump contra los migrantes especialmente
los mexicanos y los centroamericanos
y principalmente porque los cubanos los
cubanoamericanos nunca han tenido
problemas migratorios de hecho se han
beneficiado de las políticas
estadounidenses cualquiera que llegaba
hasta este país pues en un año podía
legalizar sus papeles lo mismo pasa
también con los colombianos o los
venezolanos que pueden acogerse a
algunos beneficios e inmigratorios como
el asilo por eso el tema migratorio aquí
en florida no es un tema tan importante
o tan destacable como podrían ser en
otras zonas de estados unidos como
méxico o incluso tejas donde la
población mexicana y centroamericana
también es muy abundante y realmente
bailan representar el castrochavismo o
se está traduciendo la polarización que
ya existen en sus países en la contienda
de eeuu
y cualquiera que sepa o entienda un poco
de política estadounidense sabe que este
país eeuu no se puede convertir en un
país comunista de un día para otro es un
mensaje que el presidente tram está
repitiendo una y otra vez pero detrás de
este mensaje está la posibilidad la
intención de poder captar esos votos de
la comunidad venezolana especialmente
porque si realmente se confirma que el
98 por ciento de los elegibles a votar
van a ir a las urnas pues podrían marcar
la diferencia en este estado y
recordemos que es quien gana florida
gana las elecciones de presidenciales ha
sido así desde el año 1996 y sólo en dos
ocasiones desde 1924 no había pasado
algo así gracias tanto a nivel sin
nuestro corresponsal en miami
es que la situación en colombia y
venezuela no es lo único que polariza a
los electores en eeuu aunque rara vez en
la historia del país la sociedad había
estado tan dividida pero no es
sorprendente con un personaje como
donald trump al mando que despierta
amores y odios al extremo veamos más en
la siguiente animación
sólo entre el 3 y el 4% de los votantes
estadounidenses decían que serían
indecisos a un mes de las elecciones lo
que muestra lo polarizada que está la
contienda presidencial 2020 el
porcentaje de personas que se
identifican como independientes ha caído
del 37% al 34 por ciento en los últimos
cuatro años la mayoría de los
estadounidenses se definen como
demócratas o republicanos un factor
clave donald trump 94% de los
republicanos se aprueban su gestión y
sólo el 7% de los demócratas lo hacen
las opiniones sobre barack obama también
estaban completamente divididas previo a
su reelección mientras que bill clinton
vio el 20 por ciento de aprobación entre
republicanos george w.bush cosechó
alrededor del 15 por ciento de
aprobación del lado demócrata la
separación actual es evidente sin
importar a quien apoye el 40 por ciento
de los votantes dice que no tiene amigos
en el otro lado es una división extrema
que encuentra sus raíces en el creciente
alineamiento del partido republicano con
el espectro más conservador del
electorado
según un estudio de 2019 el 36 por
ciento de los republicanos apoyan el
derecho al aborto menos del 39 en 2007
entretanto el apoyo de los demócratas al
aborto ha incrementado del 63% al 82 por
ciento lo que prueba que su demografía
ha girado a la izquierda en parte en
respuesta al éxito de las campañas de
bernie sanders para las primarias del
partido el 3 de noviembre dos visiones
radicalmente diferentes de eeuu se
enfrentan por el futuro del país
[Música]
vamos a ver la imagen de la semana amy
cón y barrett la nominada del presidente
de donald trump para la vacante de la
facticidad ruth báder ginsburg en la
corte suprema de justicia- enfrentó al
comité judicial del senado en sus
audiencias de confirmación los
demócratas la cuestionaron sobre el
futuro de casos como la ley de la salud
asequible o obamacare y los derechos al
aborto
barrett se negó a responder y solo
argumentó que no tiene una agenda es
casi un hecho que será confirmada en el
cargo debido a que los republicanos
tienen la mayoría en el senado
[Música]
donald trump y joe biden podrían debatir
nuevamente después de todo el jueves el
presidente y su rival participaron en
foros paralelos después de que el
segundo cara a cara fuera cancelado
debido a que trump dio positivo por kobe
19 el tercer y último debate está
previsto para el 22 de octubre en
nashville y se espera que sea diferente
al primero pues la comisión de debates
presidenciales anunció cambios como la
posibilidad de silenciar los micrófonos
para evitar las interrupciones
y gracias por acompañarme en esta
emisión de aquí américa recuerden que
pueden seguirme en redes sociales en la
dirección que ven en sus pantallas
cuídense mucho del coronavirus y sigan
viendo france24
[Música]